what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and i am super stoked that we
have more elton ring to go over and talk
about and with this latest update we got
a whole lot of new information
in fact so much so i almost felt like it
spoiled a little bit but that's okay
before i get into this around four
months ago i made a video about
everything we know so far about elder
ring including information from
interviews with game director hitetaka
miyazaki so there are many details i
discussed in that video i won't be
reiterating on top of that i'm sure
we'll have a whole lot more to discuss
in a week after the network test rolls
out
but all of that said let's turn on some
king's field music and discuss open
world dark souls
elder ring's recent gameplay preview
essentially takes us on a long journey
from the open world of the lands between
into and partially through a legacy
dungeon we saw a lot more about the open
world aspects of eldon ring as part of
this to make a comparison the open world
itself seems to act very similar to the
legend of zelda breath of the wild while
traversing the open world you can call
your steed at any point or dismount at
any point meanwhile you gather map
fragments as you travel to fill out the
overworld map it's unclear how to find
these map fragments but it could be
related to the various urgeries of the
game similar to how a shika tower and
breath of the wild filled out that
game's map
however unlike breath of the wild there
is no map at all within the game's
dungeons with those being far more
traditionally souls in style elder rings
map is filled with craftable materials
you can collect at different points in
the gameplay preview you can spot
various glowing collectibles that will
definitely be items your character can
pick up for crafting there are also some
wild animals roaming about and i'd
imagine that by killing these you'll
also gain some precious crafting
materials
later in the gameplay preview we
actually see the player crafting
together some sleep bone arrows the
items required are thin animal bones
flight pinion and trina's lily the thin
animal bones are acquired specifically
by hunting beasts and the flight pinion
by hunting birds so i think this all but
confirms the idea that hunting animals
will contribute meaningfully to crafting
finally there's also trina's lily which
is exceedingly rare to find so seems
like we might be told if certain
crafting materials are on the more rare
side the lands between are filled with
multiple sites of grace which would seem
to act as elder rings version of a
bonfire within the lands between these
can manifest rays of guiding light
although to what i'm not sure it's also
unclear if these are in the legacy
dungeons and if so if they'll have rays
of guiding light within those dungeons
as we saw in the first trailer you can
summon your seed anywhere within the
open world portion of the lands between
however you won't be able to ride
horseback within legacy dungeons we see
more of how a horseback dragon battle
would work it's definitely conducive for
ranged attacks like using a catalyst in
magic however while you can strike at
enemies with your sword your horse will
still keep moving so it seems like
defeating an enemy in this way would
take far longer as you won't be able to
combo attacks it's also unclear how
powerful these attacks would be compared
to attacks on the ground on top of that
further in the trailer we see a plethora
of new critical attacks and it doesn't
seem like these are possible via
horseback so while the bonus of using
your steez means you have plenty of
added speed can avoid enemies and can
even double jump via horseback your
offense might severely suffer as a
trade-off we once again see the launch
pads that your horse can take to launch
in the air and conveniently travel great
heights and now know they're called
spirit springs that said i think they're
in specific places and probably not
something you can just place at will
something i noticed when the dragon flew
in and killed some npc enemies was a
golden aura glow around the character it
seems you still absorb experience in a
similar visual fashion as the previous
fromsoft games
similar to how dark souls 3's combat was
dark souls influenced by bloodborne
elder ring looks to be dark souls 3's
combat heavily influenced by securo what
i mean by this is that in several
portions we see the importance of
stealth ala sekiro as sneaking around
was introduced in that game we're shown
a scene where the character sneaks past
enemies to avoid detection as well as
the scene where the player sneaks behind
an enemy so they can stealthily shoot
them down with an arrow after the player
essentially performs a death blow on the
enemy once again similar to securo while
there were critical strikes in previous
souls games these were strictly
performed by either parrying and
reposting or maneuvering for backstabs
now you can perform these critical
takedowns on downed enemies
next we see the player jump down and
attack an enemy from above jumping was
introduced in securo on top of that in
previous soulsborne titles you would
perform a plunging attack when dropping
down on an enemy
now it seems to be a more standard
jumping attack perhaps with more weight
to it if the game takes into account
your height as noted in the trailer this
breaks the enemy's stance allowing you
to perform a critical attack without
needing to parry first i also want to
mention death blows as they relate to
the dragon we saw earlier in the trailer
once the dragon is heard enough we see
the character perform what appears to be
a death blow and the trailer cuts before
we can see if this actually kills the
dragon or not if it doesn't that could
mean that some bosses have multiple
health bars similar to insecure however
we really don't know at all yet and i'm
sure we'll have far more mechanical
answers in a week after the network test
there are several new weapons catalyst
attacks and special weapon attacks on
display in this trailer and it's
exciting to see the level of
customization you'll have and how you'd
like to approach combat
we also see more examples of spears who
the player can summon into battle in
order to aid them while we already knew
this was possible the main takeaway i
saw was that you can also use this for
bosses as we later see this used on
godric the golden
as i mentioned earlier you'll have a map
this time around in the open world
segment of the game so let's talk about
that map for a bit while we see a good
portion of the map as well as large
chunks which are missing map fragments
we also see where the player is standing
and the direct correlation to what the
map looks like compared to the world
view one extremely notable thing both on
the map and in the world are the
urgeries these trees are the giant
golden trees we've seen several shots of
both the gameplay trailer and gameplay
preview on the map these are represented
by large glowing trees
these urge trees are a major feature of
the map and game so they must be
important but how so and what exactly do
they do from a gameplay perspective the
lore states that in the lands between
ruled by queen marika the eternal the
elden ring the source of the urgery has
been shattered supposedly there's a hub
in the game so i have two guesses either
these trees take you back to the game's
hub
or it's also possible that each tree
corresponds to a section of the map and
reaching those highly visible markers is
what will then add that section to your
map similar to breath of the wild chica
tower however that's just speculation
it's also possible there's some sort of
ability or treasure beneath or at the
base of the trees
there are a couple markers on the map
that weren't specifically mentioned one
is something that looks like it
indicates a rune this one up here looks
like a village destroyed in underwater
leading to the idea that this area might
be a marsh there's a large cave entrance
marker likely indicating a mini dungeon
within a cave and there's a wooden hut
my guess is that these are all mini
dungeons but i'm not sure why there are
so few it could be that the player has
gone within a certain range activating
the marker it could be these are ones
that are unexplored or ones the player
has finished exploring
there's also a couple of these telescope
markers unfortunately due to the mist
and distance i couldn't tell exactly
what this was from the world view
finally there's these golden direction
markers which if i'm being honest i'm
really not sure what they represent i
suggest their slice of grace with the
direction being what the guiding light
points out however considering only four
are on this map that seems pretty
unlikely on the other hand by pressing y
you open the sites of grace list
probably for a form of fast travel and
i'd have to imagine that these sites of
grace will also appear on the map
on the bottom right below the compass
the map says early day so there's a
quick and easy way to check what time it
is as the trailer itself blatantly
states you can place markers to help you
out as well as beacons for places you
want to travel that clearly show up in
the world so you won't need to keep
returning to your map to find your
destination
from the world view outside of the map
the focal point is the castle straight
ahead it's honestly unclear to me if
this is stormville castle as the
architecture looks different on a side
by side at first glance i thought it was
but then i realized the architecture of
this castle is too clean and not nearly
as harsh or falling apart like
stormville
to the left is a dilapidated cathedral
or villa and to the right are ominous
mountains that could also hold something
interesting it looks like 37 seconds in
from the first gameplay trailer far
right is a long bridge that looks like
something too distinct and you'll
probably travel across
on the map view we can see that there's
an island underneath it on the other
side to the bottom left is some sort of
camp outside of being a super pretty
shot this also shows the game has a good
draw distance much of the trailer seems
to be heading to the right side of this
area and i have a feeling this is the
section of the game we'll be seeing in
the network test i thought it would be a
good idea to check what stats the
character is given as shown in the menu
this will mostly look familiar to his
soul's vet with your general stats being
vigor likely your hp mind for your fp
endurance your stamina strength and
dexterity for different types of
physical attacks and builds intelligence
and faith for different magic builds and
arcane arcane is the interesting one
here as it's a stat that only existed in
bloodborne in bloodborne the stat
increased your ability to use most
hunter tools boosted item discovery and
gave a boost to various elemental
attacks
so in eldon ring where you can equip
different types of weapon attacks arcane
may affect that and how effective these
attacks are
but again that's just speculation
another notable change is that your
equip load isn't only shown in terms of
a fraction but you're given the
information of how heavy the load is for
your character so you won't need to roll
around to find out underneath the
character's level is runes held this
could be similar to souls in dark souls
where it's the basic number of
experience points slash currency you're
carrying with the runes being the way
you level up and or purchase items and
equipment finally we see two memory
slots at the bottom and this one i'm not
totally clear on we see the character
immediately perform special weapon
attacks after leaving the menu so i
believe you equip those onto the weapons
themselves my best guess is that memory
slots could be where you hold your
equipped spells similar to the soul
series and we just didn't see anything
here as this was a non-magic or
faith-wielding build
at another site of grace multiplayer is
finally shown in this gameplay preview
co-op is specifically shown however pvp
and invasions were reconfirmed in the
trailer while miyazaki stated these
elements would exist in an interview
it's nice to see them in action on top
of that some players online emotes now
have audio to them
hey
we're shown a co-op boss battle in this
area that's notably by a golden tree or
what i believe are the urgeries i've
been wondering if it could be this spot
we saw earlier when the character was
looking into the distance and this spot
on the map what do you think outside of
the cool abilities shown in the boss
battle one interesting element i wanted
to point out was that we see the player
both attacking the horse and jumping up
to attack the rider on top it brings up
the question of whether jumping and
attacking the rider specifically
actually hurts the boss more
something really interesting to me after
dealing with the op gravity of previous
souls games is how the player here
nonchalantly jumps down from a great
height of course it is possible they
lose some health from this fall as the
hut is turned off for this video but is
still quite the fall this seems to be
another element taken directly from
sekiro especially with the ability to
jump we do however see a drop that is
too high and the player character
clearly needs to use certain horizontal
gravestones to drop down further without
taking too much fall damage or dying
below these graves is a catacomb along
the wall
or excuse me
catacombs perhaps this is the one that
we saw on the map
catacombs excitingly these catacombs
look to be filled with traps allah sends
funhouse or kingsfield also illusory
walls are back confirmed time to swing
your weapon at every single wall in
existence wall checkers anonymous unite
before i get to the various npcs
introduced in this gameplay preview i
want to talk about stormville castle
which as we learn is within the limb
grave region if you look back at the
first gameplay trailer there's a boss
who appears on a bridge in front of a
castle to attack the approaching
tarnished this castle is in fact
stormville castle so while we didn't see
this particular boss in the gameplay
preview you can expect them to show up
guarding the way to the exterior of the
castle from the interior stormville
castle actually reminds me a lot of the
bolitarian palace in 1-1 of demon souls
i think this is supposed to be the first
area you tackle or at least meant to be
even if the game is completely
non-linear and that would make sense for
it to be a training ground of sorts like
the bulletarian palace
within stormville castle's dungeon
design it's notable that you actually
have to jump on this terrain and needing
to jump will be an additional obstacle
within legacy dungeons i'm not sure if
this specific spot with what looks like
an npc sulking in the corner is supposed
to be godric the golden walking away on
the bottom floor but i absolutely love
the detail here with all of the
disembodied arms
similar to souls before fighting godric
the golden there's a golden fog gate so
far gates are back however i wonder if
there are multiple in legacy dungeons or
only before major boss fights also if
there will be any fall gates outside of
legacy dungeons
we see two phases to the godric boss
battle the first phase shows fighting
against him with all of his arms
relatively normal however the second
shows one of his arms which was already
slightly malformed having transformed
into a dragon head godric asks a dragon
for strength so we see why and how it
pays off something i find interesting
about all of this is that when we saw
the co-op row helping our main tarnish
man fighting off a boss earlier the
co-op bro actually used a similar
technique while helping battle against
this boss earlier in the trailer so that
means one of three things either a this
technique of using a dragon's power is
somewhat common and an ability you can
gain somewhere else in the game
b an ability you gain for defeating
godric or around where godric is or c
related to the earth tree that can be
seen near or within stormvale this is
what led me to think perhaps these
archerys could grant the player
abilities such as utilizing the same
dragon arm technique that godric uses
okay so gameplay out of the way let's
talk about some npcs npc number one is
alexander the iron fist he completely
gives off sigmar vibes or seek word if
you prefer dark souls 3. this friendly
npc seems to be one of the inhuman
enemies you come across and if that
definitely is the case and it's not just
some super elaborate outfit it means you
might have to be a little more careful
when attacking enemies as to not
accidentally attack a friendly npc
another major one is melina who could be
our new emerald herald slash maiden and
black etc etc she has an interesting
tattoo or scar along her left eye but
it's hard to say what this means just
yet she tells the player i
offer you an accord so it could be we
need her to level up and you offer her
runes in order to do so
within stormville there are two npcs we
encounter one who offers friendly advice
you can either take or ignore and rajet
who states this place is bristling with
tarnish hunters you know
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting there are a couple other
npcs that tarnish seems to run past but
doesn't speak within this trailer so i
just wanted to point these instances out
we also get to see the full cutscene
shown briefly in the gameplay trailer of
godric the golden ruler of stormville
godric refers to a dragon as the true
born heir perhaps of the elden ring as
well as someone kindred so it'll be
interesting to see what this actually
means and how it plays out when we can
truly dive into the lore
so there you have a breakdown of the
alden ring gameplay preview i hope i was
able to point out some things you missed
and if there were any cool details i
missed please do share as i mentioned i
previously did a video on everything we
know so far four months ago so there may
have been some details i didn't discuss
here that i did in that video thanks so
much for watching and i hope you enjoyed
and i'll see you guys soon for more
elden ring
you